that was in Purdue University in my
first year there and I wanted to serve
and so I joined the Army Air Corps when
overseas as a pilot and b-17s
flew 29 combat missions and a couple of
missions dropping food to the debts and
flew home on my birthday and the war was
over that was my military career you've
always heard there were no atheists in a
foxhole believe me there were no
atheists in it in an airplane either but
my brother's older brothers were in the
war one was taken prisoner and was in
German concentration camp and I remember
the impact that that had on our family
and the importance of prayer at that
time
one of the visit that started all this
was we were there on a Sunday and that's
what led to Joe to say well where are
these students worshiping you know where
they going to church there's a big need
here it was interesting to me to think
that as you look at the campus you
didn't see the prominence of a place to
worship or they could go and just have
you know a quiet meditation time with
the Lord so I asked mr. Savini
why not a chapel and he said well
interesting you should mention that
that's something for the future and to
me the future is now Hillsdale has had a
chapel for most of its history in the
1850s it built the college Baptist
Church down the street well we use the
College Baptist Church today but the
college is more than twice as big as it
was back then we can't all get into it
anymore and colleges in America and in
the medieval times in Europe have always
had academic religious ceremonies we
call the main ones here are convocation
you need the whole campus community to
get together and we don't have a place
to do that that's proper for it and why
do it now
well there are a lot of reasons but one
of them is mr. Babbitt and his wife Joe
are keen for us to build it we're very
grateful for that and they've given us a
significant gift to get started on it
and if we can get the rest of the money
then now is a better time than tomorrow
the two chief ways of knowing a reason
and faith and they are different ways of
knowing and there is some significant
overlap between them and there's never
been a great university that was not
heavily concerned with the question of
God and there's never been serious
Christian practice that was not heavily
concerned with learning and to take one
of them out is to deprive it of an
essential element this chapel will be a
daily reminder of that essential fact
always remembered here never remembered
too much
the inspiration for the new Christ
Chapel
started with looking at central hall the
yellow brick the front porch the two
towers are pavilions either side the
large dart window in the middle is
actually inspired by the round window at
central hall which is the spot where
there was a chapel at one time that's
where we started what was the
inspiration for the inside the interior
of the chapel is inspired by that
quintessential English Church same are
in the fields which is the model for
most early American churches where you
have a major nave large columns
supporting a big vault and balconies
because the college wanted to have a
church that seats 1300 that would feel
intimate for 600 the balconies lead your
eye towards the pulpit towards the table
the altar and there we have an organ and
a beautiful Shirley and a window so the
interior is inspired by Sigmar in the
fields and st. martin-in-the-fields is
the model for such great churches as
Christ Church in Philadelphia where the
founding fathers met during the
Continental Congress deliberate
are concerned with that which is true so
when you're studying the liberal arts
and understanding the world around you
and what it means to be human you come
to the conclusion that to be human is to
be made in the image of God I see this
Chapel as being a visible reminder of
God's presence on the campus and his
plan for what he wants the students and
faculty to do for his kingdom I believe
that building a chapel on this campus
will be the perfect symbol of what has
been happening at Hillsdale for years
and that is the serious pursuit of truth
particularly in Scripture and generally
in all the liberal arts
the college has four purposes and they
are freedom high learning that's
the ultimate goods in nature and God the
development of high moral character in
the propagation of the Christian faith
those four things are central at
Hillsdale College they have not been
changed since 1844 so of course the
chapter that has to be right in the
middle of everything we do feel that the
placement of it is the absolute perfect
place because it just makes you aware of
God's presence on campus you know you go
by and you can't help but think that's
my faith that's the foundation that all
of this learning is the building okay
the first thing we're gonna do it is
we're gonna have convocation and Beckel
our convocation there are four of them a
year including commencement we all
gather we wear our robes the choir sings
we say prayers so then there'll also be
30 prayer group meetings a day at
Hillsdale College and there are three or
four religious services every day and
those will be held in the chapel and in
the side Chapel a home for those then
the chapel is going to be a great place
for music more than 30 percent of our
students are involved in music we have
an 85 piece Orchestra we have a hundred
and fifty people in a chorus they sing
and play a lot of sacred music the
course mostly sacred music we are going
to put in the chapel two world class
organs and we want to have choral
evensong and the major orchestral and
choral performances will be in the
chapel I came here 16 years ago the
specific reason that I decided that I
work here if they would have me and they
had said that they would is that I read
those beautiful original articles of the
college
those articles were written by New
England preachers who come to the
frontier and some of them became friends
of Abraham Lincoln and they did
wonderful things in the cause of Lincoln
so as in the founding the practice of
the Christian faith gave powerful
support to the greatest movement of
freedom in all of human history I came
here with a love for that and a wish to
make that stronger and better the chapel
is actually the last significant
structure that requires to be built to
complete that work the work will never
be complete but the structures will be
in place won't that be something I pray
for that
we didn't enter into this whole thing
with Hillsdale very lightly you know
Lourdes blessed us more than we ever
thought were possible and with a
blessing he also we have a
responsibility to him to be good
stewards all his money so where does
this money go we've prayed many times
that this would be the proper place and
we believe it is the proper place
because it will have students in there
that are going to change the world and
we need them we need them badly
you